you know when you make a statement like  that that is a very very very nasty  statement to essentially 28 including  them 28 countries I think that you know  you have a very high unemployment rate  in France France is not doing well  economically at all they're starting to  tax other people's products so therefore  we go and tax them it's just taking  place right now in technology and we're  doing their wines and everything else  and it's it's a very tough statement to  make when you have such difficulty in  France you look at what's happened with  the yellow vests or you look at what's  going on doing certain parts of this he  said they've had a very rough year and  you just can't go around making  statements like that about NATO it's  very disrespectful